[Music]
okay so the original board a brilliant
challenge was based on an extremely
mundane situation that happened to me in
that I sat down to try and come up with
some good ideas for my podcast we were
doing well I wanted to like you know I
wanted to kill it it was 2014 and I sat
down to sort of make a list which is
usually worked for me and I felt like
there was nothing there was this
blankness it was almost as though there
was sand in my brain and I started to
think like what the you know first of
all what the hell and second of all like
well wait a minute when had I had my
last best ideas and why was I
potentially having so much trouble now
and I thought back and it was really
when I was staring out the window such a
cliche it was when I was staring at the
window or I was in the shower or I was
pushing my kid's stroller for miles and
miles
that is when I had my best ideas and now
I realized that all those little cracks
in my day all those moments when I used
to sort of just be spacing out what was
I doing I was looking at this thing
right I was looking at my phone when I
was waiting in line for coffee when I
was on the bus every single one of those
moments and it made me realize like I
was never bored ever in my life anymore
in fact I might not have been bored
since I think 2009 which is when I first
got an iPhone I was a late adapter and
so then it made me think like well what
actually happens in our brains when we
get bored and what could potentially be
happening if we never get bored ever
again is if we got rid of this sort of
human state altogether is boredom
actually a useful sort of emotion so I
reached out to my audience and I was
like are you guys thinking about this
too or and you have to remember this is
a couple years ago right so are you
thinking about this are you thinking
about the fact that your phone could be
disrupting the way you think the way you
come up with ideas maybe your creativity
and people were like yes absolutely I'm
thinking about this so I put it out to
them I was like well would you be
willing to do an
with me where we take a week we try to
tweak our digital behavior and we see if
we can indeed jumpstart our creativity
by getting bored more often and I kind
of thought like 200 people would sign up
to do this or something and 20,000
people signed up within the first 48
hours so it was pretty exciting and
gratifying that you know it wasn't just
me who was feeling like there was sand
in their brain so what I wanted to
understand first of all was what
actually happens in our brains when we
get bored and it's fascinating I had no
idea that we are at this moment in
history where we are starting to
understand what happens in the brain
when we allow it to just sort of wander
where it wants where it wants to go and
so what they know now is that when you
get bored you activate a network in your
brain called the default mode and you
you can't this is different than
mindfulness right this is when you're
folding laundry or like gambling down
the street or just lying on the couch
not watching Game of Thrones and
tweeting at the same time so what
happens in the default mode is this
network ignites your most original
thinking it is where you do your best
problem-solving and you also do
something called autobiographical
planning which I had never heard of this
is where you look back at your life you
take note of the highs and the lows and
you build a personal narrative you
figure out what is your story and then
where are you gonna go from there where
does the story continue you set goals
and then you figure out the steps that
you need to take to reach those goals
now of course you can't ignite the
default mode if you are focusing on
something like your phone or if you
can't tap the brain power if you're
tapping a screen now this is extremely
important things understanding who you
are a theory of mine what you want to be
when you grow up like we all want to
know what we're gonna be when we grow up
this is really its long-term planning
and so the fear is that if people are
constantly thinking about what's the
next post that they're going to be or
being reactive or spending time
expressing outrage to the latest
headlines you can't do the deeper maybe
also difficult
thinking about who you are and what you
want to become maybe changes that you
need to make and I think you know what
was most striking to me was some of the
younger people teenagers in particular
who reached out to me and said I'm
really scared to do board and brilliant
because I'm scared to spend time alone
with my thoughts I've never done that
before I had one woman on the book tour
who said this is just too too scary I
don't I don't know how to be with myself
alone I don't think I can do this and
when you have an entire generation or
decade of young people saying that
they're fearful of being alone with
their thoughts or or getting bored and
being nervous about where their minds
might wander to that's very concerning
to me because we have some serious
issues in this country we have racial
divide we have economic discrepancy we
have we're basically divided in half and
so we need this next generation of young
people to come up with some incredibly
original and creative ideas to solve
some big problems and how can they
possibly do that if they can't even sit
alone with their own thoughts or they're
afraid to
[Music]